welcome to Jurassic from Jurassic Park
to Jurassic world et has learned that
the original stars of Jurassic Park
Laura Dern Sam Neill and Jeff Goldblum
will all be returning for 2021 s third
Jurassic world film and get this the
stars will all reprise their original
roles as dr. Ellie Sattler dr. Alan
Grant and dr. Ian Malcolm hold on dear
bucks
third drastic world movie has yet to be
titled but fans should obviously expect
a whole lot of Chris Pratt that's how it
is
et has spoken with several of the stars
about whether or not this would happen
laura has this to say in April Jurassic
world's 3 what are the chances on a
scale of 1 to 10 that we will see you
maybe oh I don't know I I have no idea
that's not a no though right I mean you
know I love dr. Ellie Sattler so I could
never I could never say no to that on
any level but I really don't know I mean
I I don't even know what they're cooking
up yet
that's unpredictability have you talked
to Chris I met Chris recently at her
restaurant know each other and it was
really funny we ran into each others
arms and hugged each other like we were
family that is so because we're both the
same but and he just seemed fantastic
and is hilarious
shortly after Chris said this I would
love I would love to see some of the
other characters from the original
Jurassic Park movies
Laura Dern oh come on don't be so
amazing and just this month Jeff said
for the chance that we can get you back
on the franchise
would you be down down
if I was any further down I'd reach in
China I'll be all the way in China
[Music]